mr. fury we're we're getting reports
there's a ship out there there's five
beans on this ship get that [ __ ]
and it's the Baxter building formerly
the Avengers tower brings them back to
the swinging sixties baby where it's a
Reed Richards because I'm going wrong
baby
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars and I am
Tommy back till the permanent host of
this show hosting rogue Theory filling
in for Philip Malina irreplaceable we do
pray for you Philip
he is currently Hall of sailor moon
tattooed on his chest yeah each one of
the gals and also what is the tuxedo cat
yeah that's Edo cat where he's getting
that we're not allowed to say they're
gonna run out of ink he's not sure he's
been working out that's why we're not so
much so you want to get the whole cast
with me to go rogue today we have the
wonderful Eric Voss thanks for having me
back absolutely great to have you back
to my show and you know one of my
favorite people of all time joven shy
I'm glad to be here on your show this is
really great this is truly wonderful and
what else can you say about this person
besides she's just so wonderful Marina
Mastro yes oh and by the way we're going
to be talking fantastic for today's
forecast
so Jonathan keeps doing interviews where
he says he wants to play Reed Richards
in a Marvel movie and Kevin Feige has
said the Fantastic Four will come into
the MCU
but we don't know how or when or do we
or do we know put your cute little heads
together and tell me how will MCU
introduce the Fantastic Four okay well I
got a theory on yes in fact it might be
a rock there that's good you're in the
right spot at the right time my friend
glad you have kept the title rogue
theory is your show you could call what
everyone's gonna be Tommy time soon
speaking of the other kind of time my
theory for how the Fantastic Four will
come into the MCU is through the series
Loki I think Loki's set up perfectly
because he we know he is gonna be
involved with a time various authorities
suggesting that he's gonna be jumping
around in different timelines now oh I'd
be why ask
Loki stole the space stone from endgame
and it's not the time stone why is he in
trouble with the time cops well he's
kind of the smoking gun evidence for
what the Avengers did to metal
the timelines and I think the TVA is
gonna hold him accountable for how
things got disrupted and we've made a
recent video about how Kang will be the
next villain at least in Loki maybe in
bigger parts of phase 4 but imagine
Loki's kind of jumping around through
different points in time one of the
places in time he could be going to is
back in time to New York City in the
1960s came back we saw some concept art
of Loki like walking around in a city in
the 1970s suggesting that we're gonna
see him going around through different
points in time as maybe he's trying to
elude the the time variants Authority
what if we saw him in the 1960s in some
kind of alternate timeline in history
and in that point in time and in that
dimension the heroes of the day were
Reed Richards Sue Storm Ben Grimm Johnny
Storm and we we could see them kind of
in this classic setting and I really
should co-credit
Pete and Reed for this because this is
essentially what he pitched for a
Fantastic Four reboot after the the two
fantastic war movies in the 2000s he
wanted to tell like a great phantom yeah
I don't know why he would want to reboot
them because they were perfect
standalone never change a thing
but would if we saw like he what he
wanted to see was the Fantastic Four in
the time period that we they originally
birdworld in the sixties and kind of
doing a he used a hard day's night the
Beatles movie it's kind of a touchstone
he wanted to see like four people run
around New York like would Beatles music
playing overhead which that's like a
really fun way Fantastic Four and then
that way we could see them kind of in
the origin story but not have to like
reintroduce them in a modern Chevy you
kind of show fans why people love these
characters in the 60s and why they were
popular to begin with and then maybe in
the way things get condensed in the
future we could see them come back to
our reality or Loki drags them into our
yeah earth-616 the reason why I love
your idea so much is because I really
want to see a scene where Reed Richards
is talking to uh
Tony Stark's dad yeah we have all three
of them they're having like a battle
boys yeah a lot of D H you know
wrinkles B yeah that's you know would it
be great as they get paid and read maybe
to just direct that episode these Disney
plus series are totally okay using em
sue directors like Taika Waititi to
direct just one episode of it let this
guy directly mantastic for story in an
episode okay yeah and then we can get a
spinoff afterwards
yeah cheerio we could have your vet
Nicole Browns character come back as
well from oh yeah oh my gosh honey he
had MUNGO JERRY facial hair yeah that's
great I like the idea of a period piece
fantastic more I like the idea of Johnny
Blaze Johnny Storm in long sideburns
yeah I'm gonna give you one Rogie for
you to mail the Peyton Reed I can follow
up that you're just a good idea and I'm
like I mentioned I would like to see
that play out because I almost want to
see the Fantastic Four as a TV series
more than ya than a single movie in the
sonic but um I see this as a pretty
strong competition so I gotta bring my
a-game here and blow your minds with
some Marble Madness here now some casual
viewers of the Marvel movies might be
like hey we've got time travel we've got
space exploration we don't know who's a
Kree or not or Scrolls so what I'm gonna
say is that Marvel's gonna do something
that they like to do when things get a
little out of hand and that's mash their
multiverses together yes we've seen a
number of times even kind of recently so
I think with Doctor Strange to a
multi-person madness coming up there's
still a lot of theories what can happen
you know multiverse in the title we're
gonna be seeing some crazy timelines
maybe he we do see a 1960s with
fantastic sure that that that could
happen but I think what will axe
happening is let's say he's fighting
nightmare which is the rumored bad guy
right now and the end because of Loki
which will be out before this movie
takes place causing these different
timelines to occur because he might
steal some of the TVA equipment or just
because the timeline isn't as it should
be he has to go through and fix the
timeline while fighting nightmare and
the only way to do so is by collapsing
all the multiverses together into one
verse verse and in that act three
explosion which hopefully isn't a large
beam into the sky we have this giant
explosion that happens and then the
nightmare gets defeated the world's
collapsed into one and Doctor Strange is
now walking around in New York again and
he feels like he's come he saved the day
everything's fine and then all of a
sudden he hears screaming and people
running away from Central Park Distance
he flies flying that direction and to
his giant surprise we get a quick shot
of him just kind of looking up and then
you hear giant stomps and camera pans
around and you just see a giant Sentinel
and then as dr. Surrey is like Tommy
chills what have I done
you see a giant optic blast destroying
Oh back but that's it can I cut two
credits now you might be thinking why
are you talking about x-men I was
thinking because I'm going wrong okay in
the post-credits thing we're gonna we
get like the nice credits and then it
cuts back to space where Nick Fury's
still on the sword base there in space
and as the the universe collapses into
one verse yeah we wind up seeing like
this this wave of energy kind of
pulsating through space and then I was
like whoa what was that again there's a
gamma storm they're often in two sectors
out mr. fury we're getting reports
there's there's a there's a ship out
there it's like what it's like yeah
there's well I'm reporting there's
there's five beans on this ship get that
mother right halfway do that first
we cut away and then we all know there
were five people on that ship you know
Fantastic Four and and a Victor Von Doom
Oh same fan how do we go into Mars
Marvel phase four or five well we just
go big we've got the Fantastic Four
there we've got x-men now we've got
Young Avengers and we're just seeing the
Marvel site guys go big no matter what
you're watching or who you want to watch
you got something something for
everybody expand again I love that see
this is what always gets me in comics
movies anything when there's so many
timelines I sort of lose my mind I get
dizzy thinking about it I love the idea
of colliding yeah I was gonna give you a
lot of roadies but I decided to collide
them all together just as a viewer where
you think like this big moment is you
get the x-men it's like it doesn't get
bigger than this they're finally doing
x-men yeah and then 30 seconds later
you're like they would have to they'd
have to space the movies out a few extra
hours because there'd be so much cleanup
necessary no you leave first I'm fine
a medical condition hydron great so not
a Doctor Strange not Loki not Loki mine
is actually a spider-man
hmm spider-man breezy mm-hmm and it's
just a taste it's just it's just an
introduction his call it like intro
biology class let's say yeah and he's
gonna ace that class they're dissecting
a spider he's like I've got this
it's very small and it pans over and
he's like hey you know past the
microscope or whatever and Johnny
and so his lab partners name is Johnny
and we don't see anything that happens
but we just get maybe like a hint or a
nod or a look or like an extra couple of
frames or something that's like four
microscopes over here like why like why
are we staying so long on this person
but actually that's Johnny Storm it's
just his Johnny's on fire no but he's
just planted as his as a character who
lives in this world a little bit younger
than we've seen him before yeah exactly
because who won't shut the f up about
wanting to be in that in the Fantastic
Four is John Krasinski as he should not
shut up continue to rain if if Tom
Holland can change what happens in the
Disney deal with Sony drunkenly calling
him then John Krasinski can change
things to what's in that cup so let's
say he's in college so really if you're
watching the movie you watch the movie
maybe you catch it maybe you don't catch
it but then in the post credit scene
right so you watch the movie it's over
oh nothing happened great
I haven't [ __ ] my pants yet what's going
on I'm just gonna get up and go to the
bathroom like a normal person not yet so
we have a post-credits scene and we see
a Johnny Storm hanging out with
spider-man their friends their science
friends yep and he's like hey do you
want to come like check out this biology
thing with me I don't know this guy's
really a science the thing he's
referring to is yeah I would have to
know more about science to really do
this dialogue but let's say it's me and
you okay so I'm Johnny Storm rocky
Parker okay and I'm like hey do you want
to go biology where I hang out and it's
cool yeah I love biology great let's go
into this how it goes and then let's go
into this giant building and then they
go up up up up up up up in the elevator
and he's like huh this tower looks
familiar and it's the Baxter building
formerly
the Avengers Tower it's been converging
that that zoom out and they're in there
going looming out into space and I like
it cuz I think we need to see Johnny
Storm and Peter Parker together all at
once yeah I like that College was such a
magical time for me it was so I like to
revisit one road this is a part that's
near and dear to my heart give it back
to me in a tweet maybe boys and girls
Loki's time hopping from the time köppen
yeah brings them back to the swinging
sixties baby where it's a Reed Richards
Oh hard day's night yeah I'm gonna make
it a little Mimi it's gonna go everybody
and Colin Blanc
yeah and then Marvel how about some
x-men in your MCU and then a bunch of
emojis and then next line also Marvel
how about some and then just like the
number four and then just like the the
nuke explosions it's gonna rhyme
spider-man keeps us all warm by bringing
in Fantastic Four with Johnny Storm
right right I'm gonna give you a quarter
or give you a quarter Oggy for memeing
quarter oh geez for everyone overall
even those were some fantastic sorry
theories fantastic episode of big
question Erik yeah yeah so Phillip and I
are currently working on this we are
looking at the question of who's gonna
like carry caps shield like who's the
worthy successor because we realized not
only is there like falcon not only is
there Bucky there's like 12 different
people who the MCU has established just
like well it could be this person or it
could be this person who's like we've
mentioned kind of by a name so I put
together our list and we realized like I
think what ultimately should determine
the next cap is who is the best shield
management skills oh that's great
so we did something crazy guys we went
outside I went outside and I saw the
blue sky for the color blue that I
thought was not the backdrop it was
actually there and thus the light was
really bright I immediately got
sunburned within five seconds and we we
did some naughty stuff we did some
vandalization we think we destroyed the
natural world a little bit we obsessive
drivers but yeah we did some to watch it
it's come in the Saturday and better
with time but we must speaking of time
move on to our favorite time-traveling
mischievous demigod maybe a god half
Dark Elf half Odin's son Loki is what
I'm talking about yeah I know it's giant
of course he is who isn't a little ice
giant I think I'm part ice giant maybe a
little bit man mates with a horse I
think oh yeah well I mean have you seen
horses they're pretty hot
mom bring some wet white kids if my kids
are watching first of all please
identify yourselves
stop watching Plus Series in a Super
Bowl ad go Buffalo Bills but as far as
we know they haven't even finished
casting yet we don't know we we know we
assume Tom Hiddleston is gonna be in it
we've heard about it Wilson right
Kessie notice was leaked this week in
one of the roles was for someone named
John who just sends a chill down your
spine oh yeah that one character named
John we've all heard of John John who is
a contentious and combative soldier with
a bit of an axe to grind Talas oldest
time so for fun for our second rogue
theory here who is John and what role
will he play in this series you got
something I have the simplest most
straightforward stupidest answer for
this so this character's name is John
right what if it's Johnny Blaze aka
Ghost Rider it's specifically played by
Nicolas Cage I will accept no other
casting it's Nicolas Cage or bus okay
we're jumping through time it's possible
you know Doctor Strange has to collapse
the time maybe that is they had to put
out a casting announcement to try to get
Mickey's attention to cage reading for
the role of John yeah National Monument
by Creative Artists Agency willing to
shave I am a local hire won't watch if
it's not blaze a great direction none
even was like a new face it has what you
said Nicolas Cage Bogey's started
flowing forth there's no amount of
roadies that is right but there are
three national treasure movies
- there's a secret third one that's
hidden underneath a Lincoln Memorial
this scale is all off so you know in
that case start inserted instead of
going for the win I'm just gonna go it's
John it's just an every average day
every everyday average name so it's not
John it's just you know placeholder so
we don't want to give too much away each
others yes it's a it's a John Doe we are
actually going to be casting for a
different generic name Matthew okay okay
Matthew Hawk and may those who know the
deep cut this is the - gun kid who in
the comics was actually held I was under
arrest by the TVA because he interfered
with the Avengers as they fought came to
conquer back in time and I think we will
be casting for a stand other cellmate of
Loki so it'll be the - gun kid so he's
been caught up by the time well and
because time all happens at once
whatever time travel that we see in
upcoming movies with let's say what came
to conquer this is something that could
all be happening at one time because
time is so timey wimey and and so we
actually see this character who also
let's go further rogue we're going raw
here rogue Rome
maybe that's because we've seen him
already do a great love to see him as a
cowboy again yeah just got captured back
to guns wow that was the worst
impression of all it's wedding she and
cage here's where it gets even deeper
the deep cut continues because they're
in that storyline where he gets captured
by the TV a she-hulk actually winds up
defending him in court and we are
getting the she-hulk Disney Plus series
and so again we're just keeping all the
data we're keeping all the Disney show
Disney Plus shows kind of intertwining
because he's a named character also he's
gonna get some more TV time you'll wind
up in a she-hulk as well and maybe even
in the movie could be like the rosario
Dawson show I like that from time
somewhere ascending upon you to rogue YZ
pretty good my I just started in one
direction didn't know what I wanted to
say and then just capture my go make it
into a video knowing okay
yeah okay so here's my theory for it I
think the name John is deliberate I
start to think okay I'm in a show that
could be dealing with like time travel
and timelines and cang and the time
variance Authority and then so John
through time who is contentious Scott
ominous got an axe to grind so I'm
thinkin maybe John is reference to like
John Connor
like going back in time a warrior
through time and who is the Marvel
Universe's Terminator Cable my friends
so cable I think they're gonna introduce
a younger version to cable in this show
and he's perfect in a show dealing with
the time variance authority someone
who's going back the time trying to
adjust timeline a TV a bounty hunter
who's working with Loki to try to right
these wrongs and they're gonna cast a
younger cable and then they might prop
in Ryan Reynolds Deadpool just as a joke
being like this is the cable who looked
like the guy I am
of course like well then some because it
looks like pianos this reality right so
I think John table for four episodes in
Loki I wasn't gonna reward one of these
but Tommy timber the equivalent currency
thing I'm gonna give you two rogue eases
what's a tiny timber okay this is the
first time a quarter gold I think
philipson comeback is like my financial
ecosystem is just ruined other cat must
play give it back to me in an
interpretive dance and can you show me
with your moves what your pitch was okay
ready put fire on my head editor and
then and then also there's a map and
then and we got to find the clues and
then it's under pyramid Bing Bing Bing
have to do sound effects for these but
you are doing it so Rockies are coming
out yeah that's right
oh he's getting up okay I mean listen if
you meant showing up naked like a
realtor yeah I would have given you all
the road you did shoot me in the head
and you didn't say I'm John and point
out the teddy bear Rogi for you alright
that's great though we should point out
our previous winner Jeff McCubbin at
evil Jeff at the evil Jeff yeah dynamic
looking very evil and his cute so
whoever wins today will
places pictures right unless Jeff comes
out in wins right now Eric what do you
have a five bogey-bogey itami timber and
a golden quarter Rogge and wow we're
sitting pretty with three and a quarter
the normal Road yeah we got the Silver
Surfer Road I have a six point two five
six point two five yep we're gonna come
down to the road questions question
where the points don't matter and
everything's made up no time to dive
will be the longest James Bond movie
ever thank God about time to my right
just won by way too fast
don't have time to die but what
unexpected thing will he have time to do
I'm gonna say get a new tailored suit
okay
a new suit any and he goes to the tailor
and he can they take the time to show
him getting fitted for this suit okay
yeah who's the one that gives them all
the weapons q QT that's right that
alright yeah what we're doing this extra
30 minutes a movie time is just what
people actually want we've got 30 more
minutes it's just him and Q just going
back and forth okay look at the new tech
explosions on there always the funnies
part of the movies 30 minutes left I
think James Bond will have time to go to
AAA and and then go one by one to the
women he pressured into having sex
[Music]
heartbreaking
our next real question Patrick Stewart
said in an interview God just make me
stop working I just want to review this
week that he became best buds with Sir
Ian McKellen when the two of them would
get drunk in their trailers during x-men
I presume in each one of the trailers
not separately over a walkie-talkie give
me your best drunken Ian McKellen or
Patrick Stewart you shall pass that
whiskey
I don't think I couldn't do another nope
make it show okay I'm so old but I still
can engage that dick little Tommy timber
for you last question for all the
marbles knives out director Rianne Ryan
right that's what I said people have
corrected me great even this in I've
been corrected twice in the last week
we're calling him Ryan Johnson like I
think it's Rianne I think you're Rhian
so my apologies two knives out director
Rory and Johnson who said this week that
Apple won't let bad guys appear on
screen with an iPhone hmm what would a
villain sound like using an iPhone for
the first time Siri how much plutonium
would I need to blow up the world
yeah mm-hmm the closest Yoshino yeah I'd
like to get a chicken teriyaki bowl and
then leave it in the Sun for a couple
hours then eat it then the FBI is
immediately notified I haven't dropped
this phone since all right I believe
that would make young Eric Voss our
winner today
because the math was too hard I think
with this very mediocre oh my god to
meet Santa that is busy here Eric bosses
wishes everyone must finish every
sentence from now on is that what you're
saying with flame on flame on nice flame
on thanks for going rogue with us flame
on thanks to our guest marina Mastro's
flame on hey fireman Twitter at Marina
masters flame on yes drove at Shire
flame on thank you for having me flame
on yeah I'm on Instagram flame on at the
joven Shire flame on am also on youtube
flame on at the Geoghan shire there as
well flame on thanks for having me back
flame on it's a great honour blame on
and keep an eye out for that big
question episode flame on and you will
really get to see Philip hardcore flame
on subscribe to the rogue theory podcast
flame on and stay tuned to this YouTube
channel for this and other shows flame
on follow us on Twitter at new rock
stars and please follow me at Tommy
Bechtold and don't forget to donate to
my legal defense fund every dime counts
we're counting on you go Buffalo Bills
go Joshi Alan forever goodbye
flame on
[Music]